A test is an order five enhanced
clones more capable than an army
yet they exhibit a concerning level of
disobedience in this regard for orders
what else you've got give me more
our squad's nothing but trouble
but we get the job done
you're clone force 99 you know
who we are hunter let's go
echo hyperdrive's online tech prepping
to jump wrecker let's blow something
I want clone force 99 found and wiped
out the galaxy's a dangerous place to be
we need to get out of here
what do you say kid you want
to come with us how can i help
the clone wars have ended
you can either adapt and
survive or die with the past
the decision is yours
we do what we do
strap in kid
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my star
wars bad batch trailer video this is going to
be the next star wars series they're dropping
episodes for starting on may the 4th which is
star wars day so may the 4th be with you there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here i'll explain where
this fits in the timeline and which other
characters are going to show up like those
mandalorian characters crossing over from the
live action series to animation which doesn't
happen very often usually characters go the other
way from animation to live action like ahsoka
like going from the ashley eckstein version of
ahsoka to the rosario dawson version of ahsoka
during the mandalorian season too but if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos and obviously spoiler
warning for everything that happened during
the mandalorian season 2 if you haven't seen
those episodes yet also there was some casting
news for the obi-wan kenobi series they're going
to be filming that soon it'll premiere next year
and they've already announced that hayden
christensen is coming back as both darth vader
and anakin skywalker but they also just announced
that they're bringing back joel edgerton's version
of owen lars and his version of aunt peru for
the series so obviously they're just trying to
tease a young version of luke but they haven't
announced who they've cast to play the really
young kid version of luke skywalker there was
all the sebastian stan talk earlier today like
sebastian stan said i would love to play luke
skywalker if mark hamill would give his blessing
and then mark hamill separately on his twitter
said you know lucasfilm doesn't listen to me when
it comes to casting so i have no say in it but he
gave sebastian stan his blessing a long time ago
and then we obviously saw what they did with
luke skywalker on the mandalorian season two
i have a feeling that they're gonna keep it
that way like they'll just keep the deep fake
version of mark hamill luke skywalker just for
continuity's sake and they'll just get better with
the visual effects on that like it looked okay but
you feel like they could have done a better job
with his face it was still a badass scene though
it was really awesome seeing luke skywalker show
up in the mandalorian after the events of return
of the jedi but the bad batch series takes place
literally right after the events of revenge of the
sith so it's all about the rise of the empire in
the idea that the clones are slowly dying off or
being killed off purposefully by the empire people
like tarkin i'll explain him too because he's not
moff tarkin and he's not grand moff tarkin yet but
at this point in the timeline you notice all their
armor is still like the white clone trooper armor
they haven't quite transitioned to the classic
stormtrooper armor and it sort of implied that
when that happens that's also when most of the
clones have died off and they fully gone back to
using regular humans but all these characters are
basically the bad batch characters they introduced
during the clone wars episodes the defect clones
that also got special abilities because of the
genetic errors in the cloning process a lot of
this footage is probably from the first episode
they explained that it was actually going to
be 70 minutes long but normally these are half
hour animation episodes in the first episode
obviously dropping may the fourth on a tuesday
but regular episodes after that will drop every
friday just like normal disney plus episodes
this version of the trailer is meant to give you a
much better idea what the story actually is so it
starts with tarkin back on the camino cloning
facility being kind of skeptical about their
usefulness and battle like is it really worth
it all these special abilities if they're so
disobedient this also lets you know that at
this point in the timeline the emperor hasn't
quote unquote shut down the camino in facility
although we know that that didn't end up happening
because he wound up cloning himself during rise of
skywalker whether or not you want to think about
those movies as canon or not but it was canon at
least before that that at some point after the
prequels he formally shut down the camino cloning
facility i know there's all these theories about
what's going on with grogu in this secret
cloning plot that moff gideon had during the
mandalorian episodes but that's much later in the
timeline in a completely separate group of people
it's just that dr perjing had the emblem of
the camino cloning facility so at some point
in the future they go back to the camino cloning
facility or on the dl and start using that
technology but the whole idea with that is that
they're trying to clone force sensitive people
that's a separate plot from what's happening with
the regular clones here in the bad batch we'll see
all that stuff play out during the mandalorian
season 3 in future seasons they administer the
test they just start ripping through all these
giant upgraded battle droids they kind of look
like the dark trooper designs from the video games
also like the dark troopers that they use during
the mandalorian series although this is a slightly
different versions so these might just be the
prototype versions of what would eventually become
the dark troopers hunter says his squad's nothing
but trouble as he speeds away from a merchant on
coruscant there's a lot of footage on coruscant in
general in all the trailers but then later during
this chase scene you see he's actually going after
ming nas fenix shan character who's wearing the
exact same armor she was during the mandalorian
season one and season two so ming na is voicing
the character like i said going from live action
to animation sort of the reverse what you would
expect she was a bounty hunter for all these
years it's also possible that boba fett shows up
because he has a strong connection to her in the
future even though they might not cross paths in
the past here at this point in the timeline right
after the events of revenge of the sith boba fett
is still very very young but he's kind of coming
into his own as a bounty hunter himself so he
would have been active around this period you see
them taking out more battle droids on a separate
planet which might just be remnants from the end
of the war like hold out separatists or warlords
trying to repurpose them for their own personal
armies then back on kamino they meet another young
clone who like them seems like he has some genetic
abnormalities notice he has blonde hair he has
that special head piece just showing you that
he is different from other clones but then after
things seem like they go south and tarkin orders
the regular clone troopers not the full-blown
imperial stormtroopers yet to hunt them down
and destroy them the bad batch offers to take this
new clone with them like hey kid you want to come
with us then you see them on that separate planet
amidst the wreckage of all the republic cruisers
which the empire is now slowly in the process of
evolving into the imperial era of star destroyers
then you see them in some other episode on some
other planet looking like these clone troopers are
trying to take over the area but the bad batch
uses one of these other walkers to attack the
clone troopers all while you get this voiceover
from another new character who's all about adapt
or die which is essentially the character arc for
the bad batch and sort of describes the fate of
all clones they have to decide in the rise
of the empire whether or not they're going
to adapt to the new political climate the
state of the galaxy or die with the past
literally die like the other clones wind up dying
off slowly over time i think by about 10 or 15
years after the events of revenge of the sith most
of the clones had died off and just for reference
the events of the obi-wan kenobi series with
hayden christensen and ewan mcgregor coming back
that takes place about 10 years after revenge
of the sith one of the big theories about their
characters that i really like too i don't know if
they're going to pay this off during the series
is the whole idea of who saved grogu from the jedi
temple during order 66. a lot of people think that
it's r2d2 which i think is a solid theory i'll
explain his connection to grogo too because
obviously they shared that scene at the end of
the mandalorian season too but r2 would have
had history with grogu going back years that a lot
of people think that it was a sith or some people
even think that it may have been anakin skywalker
himself although they've been all kinds of memes
about him hiding out during order 66 with people
editing him in using deep fakes to all these
classic prequel scenes but i think the idea is
that eventually as they slowly tease grogu's story
out on the mandalorian season 3 future seasons
the other spin-off series like the ahsoka series
eventually we will learn who wound up saving him
but they don't want to reveal all of his backstory
right away you have to remember that grogu is the
same age as anakin skywalker although obviously
he's dead after the events of return of the jedi
and grogu is still alive but grogu is in his 50s
now that's about how old anakin skywalker would
have been but grogu actually came to the jedi
temple years before anakin skywalker came to the
jedi temple so eventually when anakin skywalker
came along and r2d2 was there with him while
he was training as a jedi with obi-wan kenobi
they would have run into grogu who would have
also been training under other jedi masters the
way ahsoka explains it after she got done talking
to grogu is that grogu had studied under many jedi
masters and spent a long time at the jedi temple
so there's no way that they wouldn't have bumped
into him at some point when they were running
around the jedi temple during the prequels when
anakin skywalker was growing up you also have to
remember that ahsoka also unwittingly helped darth
maul escape at the end of the clone wars so he's
also in the process of building back his power
base in the crimson dawn crime syndicate right
now so when this series is happening we're still
a couple years before the events of solo a star
wars story based on the color of his insignia here
tarkin actually looks like he's a major general
at this point also during this period the brand
newly minted sith lord darth vader would have been
going around the galaxy hunting down the rest of
the jedi that escaped the initial wave of order
66. if you haven't read the comic book there's a
vader rising comic that basically explains a lot
of this storyline this part of the timeline for
him he basically just goes around killing as
many jedi and force sensitives as he can find
one of the reasons why he wants to get rid of
all these force-sensitive people even if they're
willing to turn is because he doesn't want the
emperor to be able to train another replacement
so even this early after anakin skywalker's turn
to darth vader he's already trying to work against
the emperor he never trusted him at any point
if that wasn't clear and the emperor on the
other side of this equation also always expected
darth vader to betray him so all these years all
the way up to the events of return of the
jedi they were playing this cat and mouse
game trying to out maneuver each other maybe
we'll see a little bit of that happening during
the obi-wan kenobi series when we get hayden
christensen's darth vader storyline remember
this december the book of boba fett episodes are
going to start releasing around christmas week
and then after that we'll get the mandalorian
season 3 episodes but they haven't given us an
exact release date for that it'll just be sometime
early next year while you wait for everything
click here for all my mandalorian season 3 videos
and click here for my full falcon and winter
soldier episode 5 trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!